nos petits-enfants
nous avons besoin de garanties de
sécurité
solides
et à le temps de cette tribune du
français je voudrais appeler l'Europe et
la communauté Atlantique
rapidement et sans limitation
accepte reçoit un guerrier qui revient à
la maison après une guerre terrible un
guerrier qui a gagné qui a protégé sa
famille sa terre
notre avenir européen
le statut de candidat à devenir membre
de l'Union européenne je rappellerai
quand en mars de l'année dernière lors
du sommet de leader à Versailles c'est
la pression de la France qui a permis
d'infléchir la situation
ont adopté une décision de prendre le
crâne et de le faire de l'ukrainement de
lieu quel que soit le développement des
événements
de Balzac qui comme vous savez à trouver
son amour en effet pour
atteindre un objectif il faut tout
d'abord y aller
en tant que chef du parlement ukrainien
je puis vous assurer que nous allons de
manière certaine vers notre objectif à
travers de manière efficace sur
l'adoption des décisions et des réformes
nécessaires des lois ne sont pas
forcément conscients que l'entrée dans
l'Union européenne ce n'est pas une
prostance simple le président de le
prendre le Parlement le gouvernement
font preuve de manière constante de la
tolérance zéro à l'égard de la
corruption et se battent contre ce
phénomène
des démissions et des arrestations des
fonctionnaires peuvent scrupuleux
aujourd'hui nous recevons de l'Ukraine
des signaux sur le fait que le front
antipruption continue son travail
aujourd'hui il y a des perquisitions
exceptionnel aujourd'hui par la société
exige que chaque personne chaque
personne
est un pays européen qui professeure et
bien il doit emporter la responsabilité
juridique
à l'Ukraine se produit pour la première
fois depuis 30 ans chers
recommandation
établie par la Commission européenne et
entamer les de notre entrée plein
entière dans l'Union européenne du
supersuadé que très rapidement
sera évident le GRAINE peut et doit
avoir le statut demande par un tiers au
sein de l'Union européenne et ça doit
être fait de manière dynamique et
efficace
également sur le soutien de la France
amicale
civile
dans le temps dans le contexte du sommet
de l'Alliance qui aura lieu le 11 12
juillet 2023 le crâne ne peut pas rester
en dehors du contexte or Atlantique
chers amis
en France que de 100 000 citoyens
ukrainiens
citoyens de l'Union européenne
je vous remercie
on peut se lessitudes pour nos enfants
qui ont intégré vos écoles
leur mère qui s'occupent de ses enfants
et vous occupez d'elle votre propre
histoire a donné à nos peuples à nos
cultures plus d'une chance de nous
réunir cette chance a lieu également
aujourd'hui comme j'ai déjà évoqué dans
vos
amis il y a un phénomène historique qui
s'appelle Lolo de mort la famine
criminel du gouvernement de Staline des
millions d'ukrainien ont péri et
aujourd'hui le signal de la part de la
France président de la reconnaissance du
rendement comme je ne cite du peuple
craignant sera extrêmement important
quand les événements de 1932-33 confirme
l'intention du pouvoir de Staline de
l'époque et de la Russie quotidienne
aujourd'hui
du coup de l'histoire moderne de
détruire l'identité
ukrainienne je voudrais appeler tous les
présents à soutenir le projet de
résolution de reconnaissance de la
famille 32 33 en tant que je ne cite du
peuple craignant
qui a été présenté par Madame
le ton et la présidente du groupe
d'amitié francs Ukraine au Sénat madame
solo monsieur le Président en
s'adressant l'été dernier aux Ukrainiens
depuis la tribune du Parlement ukrainien
vous avez dit à très juste le titre que
l'âme européenne et les idéaux sont
réalisés aujourd'hui par incarner
aujourd'hui par le peuple craignant
notre hymne national a une ligne
importante
on donneront notre âme et nos corps pour
notre liberté et nous prouverons frères
que nous sommes de la ligne casa
la liberté et notre idéal est la vie
dans une grande et libre famille
européenne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
sans aucun doute quand la vérité de
notre côté il nous reconstruiront sans
aucun doute le crâne libre et
indépendante n'avons pas le droit de
perdre notre chance historique
je vous remercie de votre attention
gloire et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci monsieur le Président je vais
maintenant suspendre notre séance elle
sera reprise à 15h15 précise pour les
questions au Gouvernement je vais
raccompagner maintenant notre hôte la
séance est suspendue
voilà pour ce moment historique que vous
devez vous venez de vivre en direct sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat depuis 14h30
un moment historique comme l'a rappelé
Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat car
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de la chambre haute du parlement qu'un
président d'un parlement de pays en
guerre a pu prononcer un discours à la
tribune du Sénat le président de la
radar la chambre l'unique chambre du
Parlement
ukrainien qui a été applaudi pendant de
longues secondes c'est encore le cas au
moment où je vous parle applaudi par des
sénateurs qui étaient debout dans
l'hémicycle à la fin de son discours et
bien ce président de la radac qui a pu
adresser des messages à la France qu'a
pu déjà remercier la France il a rappelé
que par exemple 100 000 citoyens
ukrainiens ont été accueillis dans
l'Hexagone depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine il a aussi pu adresser des
messages très politiques
propose d'écouter un extrait de son
discours avec l'une des premières
demandes de et bien elle se président à
la France écouté
[Musique]
qui en juillet de l'année dernière c'est
rendu en Ukraine et on est revenu comme
vous l'avez dit à l'époque totalement
transformé différentes c'est un acte de
courage de vraies amis
notre discours inspiré au parlement
ukrainien a été entendu par toutes les
crèmes
passionnée par le députés du Parlement
par les militaires offrons et par tous
ceux qui aident
l'esprit invaincu de la France
l'esprit des Parisiens libre qui il y a
230 ans
sont allés à la suite de la Bastille oui
aujourd'hui nous les Ukrainiens nous
prenons notre bassine voilà donc pour
l'hommage qu'a rendu le président de la
Rada ce Parlement ukrainien à l'esprit
français et puis il y a eu des demandes
très concrètes notamment sur la question
des armes à une question aujourd'hui
essentielle Quentin le président de la
radar qui a effectivement parlé de ses
avions blindé lourds et moyen de défense
aériennes dont a besoin l'Ukraine et
bien face à la saillant russe il l'avait
déjà fait notamment dans le journal Le
Monde je voudrais vous montrer cette
interview parue aujourd'hui et russein
Stephen show qui avait salué l'attitude
de la France pour commencer il a dit
c'est la France qui la première a appelé
à fournir des chars en faisant la
promesse de mettre en disposition des
blinds délégiés
amx-10rc je suis venu pour la remercier
de ce soutien mais aussi pour lui
demander de poursuivre son aide en
particulier militaire j'espère qu'elle
sera cohérente et fournira elle aussi
est des charges et le président de la
Rada de plaider en faveur de la
livraison d'avions de combat c'est ce
qu'il a redit il y a quelques secondes à
la tribune du Sénat je propose de
l'écouter nous espérons sincèrement que
la France pas la première à donner à
l'Ukraine c'est les avions modernes
RC ont déjà fait leur preuve sur le
champ de bataille
parmi les militaires des forces armées
sont sésame qui nous aident à contenir
efficacement à l'ennemi voilà ta maman
historique on l'a dit et il est rare de
voir voilà c'est le moment où l'histoire
se joue dans l'hémicycle et on a vu
aussi c'est très longues standing
ovation elles étaient très
impressionnantes depuis la tribune de
presse du sénatham retour au programme
normal de nos mercredi sur Public Sénat
avec les questions gouvernement à 15h15
donc Tam
Quentin on vous retrouvera à ce moment
là effectivement c'était un moment d'une
grande intensité ces moments d'ovation
debout au président de la Rada le
Parlement
ukrainien et puis on va rejoindre tout
de suite et bien alexandre Poussin salle
des conférences avec le président de la
commission des affaires européennes
Jean-François Rapin il a été question de
l'Europe aussi dans le discours tout à
l'heure du président rooseland Stephen
chouk notamment et bien alors que
l'Ukraine est aujourd'hui candidate à
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne
effectivement entamé le président de la
rade ukrainienne qui a demandé une
adhésion si possible rapide à l'Union
européenne Jean-François Rapin est-ce
que la France doit et bien faire
pression pour que le crâne devienne
rapidement membre de l'UE
relâcher l'escalade c'est une chose mais
finalement aujourd'hui on en est réduit
à fournir des armes à soutenir l'Ukraine
pour quelle raison parce que la Russie a
tenté d'envahir l'Ukraine et donc la
France doit monter d'un cran dans la
fourniture d'armes à l'Ukraine en
envoyant des Charlots des avions de
chasse alors ce qui a demandé le
président est en discussion le président
de la radar devant le Sénat à insisté
pour les avions c'est des discussions
diplomatiques qui vont s'engager
certainement il y a aussi un souci c'est
que la France elle-même ne doit pas
complètement se démunir de son armement
la loi de programmation militaire qui va
être étudié et voter dans quelques temps
il est important qu'on comprenne en
compte à la fois notre propre armement
mais aussi celui et l'effort qu'on doit
continuer à fournir pour armer l'Ukraine
autre demande du président de larada que
la France se reconnaisse la Russie comme
un état terroriste ce qui entraînerait
le bannissement de la Russie notamment
sur certains événements comme les Jeux
Olympiques Paris 2024 vous êtes
favorables plusieurs
états m'ont il faut voir comment on va
avancer dans les dans les démarches on a
juste un petit problème on va voir
comment on va avancer dans dans les
démarches notamment de tribunal
international ce qui est demandé
à avancer sur sur cette volonté de
l'Ukraine de déclarer la Russie comme
état terroriste pour l'instant le statut
et celui d'Etat belliqueux d'État en
guerre d'État agresseur c'est une étape
supplémentaire qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudrait qu'il faudrait pousser là mais
je pense que la France pourrait être
entraînée dans cette démarche merci
beaucoup à Jean-François Rapin d'avoir
répondu à mes questions c'est à vos
talent merci beaucoup Alexandrie on va
continuer à les réactions sales des
conférences puisque va vous répondre
maintenant Claude malurey le président
du groupe Les Indépendants le président
du groupe les indépendants qui avaient
interpellé le gouvernement la semaine
dernière autour de l'Ukraine c'était la
première question aux questions au
Gouvernement la semaine dernière c'est à
VOUS Alexandre actuellement avec Claude
malurel présent du groupe Les
Indépendants bonjour Claude Malleray
bonjour d'abord peut-être une réaction
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti dans ce
discours historique du président du
parlement ukrainien dans les mystique du
Sénat français ouais je pense que comme
tout mes collègues j'avais vu leurs
réaction beaucoup d'émotions beaucoup de
respect une standing ovation pendant
plusieurs minutes je crois que ça montre
bien et c'était important de le savoir
que le soutien des Français à l'Ukraine
et et massivement obtenu
sur tous les bancs du Sénat c'est
unanime la proposition de résolution que
nous devons examiner pour condamner
l'agression russe mardi prochain je
pense sera voté à la très grande
majorité j'espère même à l'unanimité
j'avais peur sans doute chez des balles
seuls que l'hiver voit c'est roder un
petit peu le soutien de l'opinion
publique à l'Ukraine il n'en est rien au
contraire plus les images d'atrocité de
crimes de guerre de contre l'humanité
ce sont publiés à la Télévision et plus
l'opinion condamne cette agression je
pense que l'accueil qui a été fait
montre bien l'accueil qui a été fait au
président de la radar ukrainienne montre
bien le soutien du Sénat et à travers
lui le soutien de l'ensemble des
Français est-ce que la France doit
fournir des avions de chasse à l'armée
ukrainienne c'est ce qu'a demandé le
président de la radar l'aide des avions
français je pense que il faut que la
France l'Europe les États-Unis
l'ensemble des alliés fournissent à
l'Ukraine le maximum de ce dont on a
besoin je l'ai déjà dit je lui ai dit
très clairement lorsqu'il s'agissait des
chars je comprends bien le problème
qu'il peut y avoir concernant les avions
et notamment les problèmes de
débordement sur des territoires voisins
par conséquenté d'une question difficile
pour ma part et à titre personnel j'y
suis favorable vous êtes favorable en
quelques mots pour conclure l'adhésion
de l'Ukraine rapide à l'Union européenne
et à l'OTAN vous êtes favorable je pense
les gens par rapport à tous ceux qui ont
adhéré à l'Europe depuis un certain
nombre d'années l'Ukraine a une
différence c'est qu'elle l'a payé le
prix du sang c'est qu'elle a montré par
la mort de ses soldats par la mort de
l'ensemble de beaucoup de membres de sa
population à quel point elle tenait à
être membre de la famille européenne à
quel point elle tenait à être au monde
de l'Alliance atlantique et la moindre
des choses c'est qu'on puisse leur
permettre de d'y accéder rapidement
merci beaucoup Claude malurey oui un
l'Ukraine membre de cette famille
européenne c'est un peu ce qu'on retient
de ce discours du président de la Rada
cet après-midi merci
qui a beaucoup Alexandre pour toutes ces
réactions et je suis avec Hervé Moret
Cinémateur Union centriste de l'heure
vous avez été le président pendant 10
ans du groupe France - suprême vous en
êtes aujourd'hui président d'honneur
c'est la première fois depuis 20 ans que
le président d'une assemblée d'un pays
étranger monte ainsi à la tribune du
Sénat c'est un moment d'une grande
sérénité c'est un moment important oui
c'est un moment c'est un moment
solennelle mais aussi plein d'émotions
et cette émotion répondait à l'émotion
que que j'ai ressenti quand j'ai
accompagné Gérard Larcher devant la la
Rada à Kiev au mois de juillet où il a
reçu et que c'est délégations un accueil
chaleureux tout à fait exceptionnel et
quand parfois on dit mais à quoi ça sert
d'y aller pourquoi y aller ça changera
rien je crois que les Ukrainiens ont
besoin qu'on leur témoigne notre
solidarité notre amitié et notre soutien
on l'a fait en allant en Ukraine on l'a
fait aujourd'hui on le fait aujourd'hui
on accueillant de manière solennelle et
amicale le président de la Rada je crois
que c'est important parce que c'est dans
des moments difficiles comme ça que l'on
prouve vraiment son affiché vis-à-vis de
vis-à-vis d'un pays vis-à-vis d'une
nation victime qui plus est d'une
agression tout à fait violente et
barbare ça sera le cas aussi avec le
vote d'une
prochain ce n'est pas que de l'ordre du
symbole pour vous ce qui va être voté
une résolution qui insiste sur la lutte
contre l'impunité et la nécessité de
poursuivre tous les auteurs de crime
commis par les forces russes sur le sol
ukrainien le vote d'une résolution c'est
forcément du domaine du symbole mais les
symboles sont importants et notamment
comme je l'évoquais tout à l'heure pour
manifester un soutien pour manifester un
soutien à l'Ukraine pour manifester une
condamnation de de de de la Russie et de
ce qu'elle commet actuellement et je
crois que c'est très important vous
savez c'est comme quand on a un ami qui
est dans l'adversité quand on vient lui
témoigner son amitié sa règle pas ses
problèmes mais ça ça ne soutien je crois
que c'est important en plus et c'est là
l'essentiel la France n'est pas
seulement dans le le soutien moral il y
a vous en avez parlé on en reparlera
sûrement un soutien matériel un soutien
humanitaire et un soutien militaire
qu'il faut sans doute d'ailleurs encore
intensifié et donc il y a toutes ces
formes de soutien à ce peuple qui le
mérite et qui mérite aussi
de notre admiration parce que personne
imaginait que le peuple ukrainien
résisterait comme il résiste ferait
preuve d'autant de courage et de
résilience et arriverait à infliger des
des revers sévères à la Russie et quand
je dis personne je peux dire au premier
rang desquels certainement pas les
Russes très bien que les soldats russes
sont ont commencé le combat en ayant
déjà dans leur sacoche les tenues de
gala pour défiler dans Kiev donc
vraiment je crois que l'attitude
héroïque des Ukrainiens est tout à fait
remarquable et doit être souligné et
soutenu et encouragé il faut les
soutenir en livrant pour vous des avions
de combat à l'Ukraine c'est ce que
réclamait encore le président de la Rada
tout à l'heure écoutez il faut les
soutenir pour que ce conflit dure le
moins longtemps possible nous n'avons
pas d'autres alternatives d'autres choix
d'autres possibilités que de permettre à
l'Ukraine de gagner cette guerre et bien
merci merci beaucoup Hervé Moret d'avoir
répondu à mes questions les questions au
Gouvernement commencent voilà justement
on va rejoindre donc Quentin dans
l'hémicycle du SA pour le programme un
peu plus classique un peu plus habituel
de nos mercredi après-midi
il est 15h15 mais vous le voyez c'est
Roger caoutchi qui a pris la présidence
de séance puisque j'ai marché est allé
raccompagner le président du parlement
ukrainien et donc effectivement comme la
semaine dernière vous allez le voir des
thèmes sur la réforme des retraites mais
aussi sur ORPEA ce sont deux des grands
sujets majeurs alors que la science va
pouvoir commencer d'un instant à l'autre
le temps que les sénateurs regagnent
leur siège avec cette séance commençait
donc légèrement en décalage par rapport
à d'habitude pour suivre effectivement
ce ce discours du président de la radam
et avec Isabelle borne est installé ici
vous le voyez et c'est parti pour cette
séance on rejoint les mystiques l'ordre
du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement je vous
rappelle que la séance est retransmise
en direction Public Sénat sur notre site
internet au nom du bureau du Sénat
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues à obser comme nos échanges
l'une des valeurs essentielles du Sénat
le respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
uns ou des autres ou de celui du temps
de parole
la parole est d'abord à madame la
Présidente Pascal gruni pour le groupe
les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
a même la première ministre depuis une
semaine la mobilisation sociale contre
la réforme des retraites paralyse notre
pays provoquant une nouvelle fois
l'exaspération de nos compatriotes
dépendants des transports publics comme
d'habitude ce sont les Français les plus
fragiles qui sont pénalisés ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se permettre de prendre des
jours de congés ni télétravailler et qui
n'ont d'autre solution de transport que
le train le bus ou le métro il n'est pas
acceptable qu'une minorité de Français
prennent ainsi en otage les salariés qui
veulent travailler mais aussi nos
artisans et commerçants déjà lourdement
impactés par les cris sanitaires
énergétiques si le droit de grève est
garanti par la Constitution il n'est pas
pour autant un droit de blocage de tout
autre de tout un pays bien que la loi de
2007 est organisée l'information des
usagers en cas de grève elle n'a
cependant pas permis aboutir un service
minimum garanti c'est ce qui a conduit
le Sénat à adopter le 4 février 2020 une
proposition de loi de notre collègue
président Bruno Retailleau permettant
enfin de limiter le droit de grève si
cela s'avère nécessaire pour garantir un
service minimal madame la Première
ministre ne croyez-vous pas qu'il est
grand temps de reprendre ce texte à
votre compte et de le faire adopter dans
les meilleurs délais
merci chers
ce qui répond à la
merci Monsieur collègue d'écouter les
questions parce que s'il y a du
Charivari ça peut être aussi envers vous
tout à l'heure donc restons calme allez
on vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur Clément bonne ministre délégué
des transports
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente grunis comme vous je veux
penser aux nombreux Françaises et
Français qui ces derniers jours et à de
nombreuses occasions vivent
malheureusement douloureusement les
perturbations dans nos transports
publics et sont empêchés parfois de
retrouver leur famille d'aller
travailler et dans un certain nombre
d'activités essentielles et nous devons
je crois agir avec à chaque fois deux
orientations extrêmement claires d'abord
le respect évidemment de nos grands
principes notamment le droit de grève
qui vous le savez est inscrit et garanti
par notre Constitution et puis bien sûr
de la manière la plus concrète et
pratique possible l'intérêt des usagers
pourquoi je crois quand la matière il
est essentiel de ne pas se nourrir de
slogan mais d'avoir des réponses
extrêmement efficaces précises et
concrètes la question d'un service
minimum fait partie de ces réflexions
anciennes la réalité c'est que si on le
définissait en termes de pourcentage de
services je crois que on ne répondrait
pas à la problématique que vous évoquez
pourquoi parce que si on définissait un
seuil extrêmement de services cela
serait jugé sans doute inconstitutionnel
puisque cela serait une atteinte
disproportionnée au droit de grève
garanti par notre loi fondamental et si
on définissait un pourcentage de
services trop bas on serait pas efficace
parce que même quand il y a des
mobilisations très importantes nous
l'avons vu par exemple à Noël avec les
contrôleurs de la SNCF heureusement
d'ailleurs plus de 50 % du service reste
assuré mais en signe de nombreux
Français sont pénalisés et donc je crois
d'ailleurs dans l'esprit la loi de 2007
qu'il faut que nous cherchions et c'est
cela réflexion que nous avons engagée
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
à regarder les réponses concrètes
efficaces complémentaires à certains
nombres d'ailleurs sont entre les mains
de nos entreprises publiques et nous
avons d'ores et déjà demandé aux
dirigeants des grandes entreprises
publiques de veiller par exemple à ce
que les puissiez avoir une mobilisation
interne qui soit renforcée cela
nécessite de l'organisation et de
l'anticipation puisque il faut parfois
déshabilitations de sécurité pour
exercer certaines fonctions dans nos
transports publics ça c'est une réponse
que nous devons et que nous pouvons
renforcer dans les semaines et dans les
mois qui viennent nous pouvons là encore
d'ailleurs dans l'esprit de la loi 2007
réfléchir à la question des délais de
prévenance qui sont aujourd'hui ça a été
instauré dans la loi de 2007 de 48
heures qui pourraient être débattue et
nous pourrions travailler collectivement
à réfléchir à leur extension et puis
j'entends aussi parfois dans le débat
beaucoup de choses qui sont votre temps
est écoulé merci la parole est
maintenant Madame Nathalie Goulet pour
le groupe Union centriste ah pardon
pardon pardon
pardon non non vous applaudirez tout à
l'heure je ne voulais pas voler les 34
secondes de madame la Présidente
gruonique
Monsieur le Ministre moi j'entends bien
mais depuis 2020 on aurait pu travailler
sur sur ce sujet ensemble moi j'ai été
le rapporteur de ce texte nous avons
fait des propositions tout ce que je
vous dis en fait on a bien sûr une
solution derrière franchement on vous
demande quelque chose de ferme parce que
on en a besoin on en a besoin pour
l'économie de la France on peut pas
pénaliser aujourd'hui tous les
travailleurs il y a des gens dans la rue
ok mais tous ceux qui restent chez eux
qui ne peuvent pas faire grève peut-être
et surtout qui ont besoin de travailler
c'est à eux qu'il faut penser c'est
toujours notre intérêt merci merci
la parole est vraiment cette fois-ci à
Madame Nathalie voulait pour le groupe
Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues nous sommes nombreux
sur tous ces bancs à avoir soutenu la
révolution en Iran et notamment en
parrainant des prisonniers torturés
violets condamnés sans avocat ou encore
pendus depuis plusieurs semaines l'Iran
menace la France et les soutiens de la
Révolution
massacamery réfugiés politiques a vu ses
parents menacés en Iran massid alinéja
qui est le évidemment l'emblématique
résistante reçue par le Président de la
République a échappé de justesse ces
derniers jours à un attentat aux
États-Unis on pense à sa man rouge dit
la menace est gravissime un grand
hebdomadaire titre et vous l'avez
peut-être lu pourquoi l'Iran cible la
France qui est quand même inquiétant le
général iranien Hussein salami prévient
les musulmans se vengeront vous
arrêterez les assaillants mais les morts
eux ne reviendront pas quant au ministre
des Affaires étrangères iraniens il
déclare nous ne permettront pas au
gouvernement français de dépasser les
limites et s'interroge pas si eux ont
dépassé les leurs le gardien de la
Révolution ont leur milice à l'étranger
et une branche armée capable d'agir
partout dans le monde enfin les frappes
israéliennes contre les usines de drone
à Isfahan ce weekend
sont venus aussi
interférer et craignent et nous
craignons évidemment une escalade si on
prend en considération les accords de
défense entre l'Iran et le Qatar le rôle
de la Russie et celui de la Chine la
situation risque de dégénérer notre site
Sécurité et clairement menacé dans ces
conditions madame la ministre ma
question est simple quelle mesure
entendez-vous prendre ou avez-vous
prises pour protéger les Français
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
Madame Laurence Boon secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'Europe
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice Goulet je crois que nous
partageons les constats en ce qui
concerne la préoccupation créée par
l'Iran d'abord en raison de la montée
des tensions dans la région bien sûr en
raison de la répression qui se poursuit
à l'encontre des manifestants et pour
les raisons que vous évoquiez avec les
menaces que vous venez de mentionner
nous répondons en européen avec des
sanctions et pour accompagner les
revendications légitimes des hommes et
des femmes iraniens les garantir qu'il
n'y aura aucune impunité pour les
auteurs de la répression et de ses
menaces comme vous savez il y a eu
quatre trains de sanctions européennes
78 individus 27 entités sanctionnées
dont plusieurs ministres et aux
responsables des Gardiens de la
Révolution
il y a également eu un Conseil européen
avec des conclusions qui vont nous
permettre d'agir dans et qui recouvre
tous les axes de déstabilisation
iraniens y compris d'ailleurs les prises
d'otages
les sanctions prises à l'encontre de
personnalités européennes je crois
participent du même aveuglement que
celui avec lequel le régime iranien
s'enferme dans le déni dans la
rhétorique complotiste et mène une
politique scandaleuse d'otage de l'État
et les sanctions qui sont prises par les
Iraniens n'ont évidemment aucune
comparaison possible avec les sanctions
prises par les l'Union européenne et
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour
continuer d'injecter du dialogue dans
cette région troublée et bien évidemment
protéger les ressortissants visés merci
merci Madame Goulet 25 secondes oui
c'est un peu de la même ministre l'Iran
est un état terroriste nous voudrions
que les Gardiens de la Révolution soient
inscrits sur la liste des organisations
terroristes comme si financer le sbola
attaquer les ambassades fournir des
drones à l'Ukraine et nous venons
d'entendre le président de la Rada on
n'était pas suffisant pour déclarer les
Gardiens de la révolution sur la liste
des organisations terroristes alors les
jeunes meurent en prison aujourd'hui
monsieur Borel ne veut rien faire nous
avons nous aurons la guerre et
aujourd'hui nous avons le déshonneur
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Pascal
ça vole Delhi pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
le Président mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre monsieur Duchamp le
ministre de la transformation et la
fonction publique Stanislas Guérini qui
n'a pas pu être présent à envoyer il y a
quelques jours une vidéo par mail
il y vantait les bienfaits de la réforme
des retraites de votre gouvernement qui
pourtant ne cessent de perdre en
popularité et même au sein de vos rangs
de très nombreux fonctionnaires ont été
choqués de recevoir sur l'art l'adresse
mail personnelle via la direction
générale des finances publiques une
telle vidéo de propagande monsieur le
ministre trouvez-vous éthiquement et
démocratiquement légitime et justifiée
de diffuser une telle vidéo de
commercialisation de cette réforme
résolument non négociable
c'est
pour répondre la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier dussope ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateurs
et son application pour la fonction
publique et je tiens d'abord à dire que
si
mais
je sens impatient mais
laissez-moi aller au bout de la réponse
on dirait que je répondrai à tout mais
d'abord pour vous dire que le ministre
de la Fonction et la transformation et
la fonction publique à trouver utile de
dire aux fonctionnaire quels étaient les
dispositions comprises dans cette
réforme et en slash je pense que c'est
un exercice de transparence qui est
utile mais sur le fond que faisons-nous
avec cette réforme et en quoi cela
concerne les fonctionnaires d'abord ça
les concerne comme l'ensemble des actifs
en France avec un relèvement progressif
de l'âge de départ à la retraite de deux
ans et avec la volonté de maintenir
aussi les spécificités du régime de
retraite de la fonction publique
c'est-à-dire un mode de calcul des
pensions sur les 6 derniers mois en
précisant d'emblée que le taux de
remplacement n'est pas plus important
dans le système public que dans le
système privé et en maintenant pour les
agents publics les bénéfices des
catégories actives le bénéfice des
catégorie actifs c'est un point
important puisque vous le savez monsieur
le sénateur il y a à la fois la volonté
du gouvernement de faire en sorte que
les agents catégories actifs qui
débutent leur carrière dans ces corps
d'emploi avec un statut de contractuel
puisse voir ces années contractuelles
prises en compte pour la durée de
service actif leur permettant un départ
anticiper nous voulons aussi mettre en
place la portabilité de la fonction
catégories de la fonction publique pour
faire en sorte que un surveillant de
prison ou un officier de police puisse
après deux passages dans sa carrière
bénéficier des mêmes droits s'il a
travaillé 30 ans dans deux corps que
s'il avait travaillé dans 30 ans dans un
seul corps nous mettons aussi fin
je me sens particulièrement nerveux
partir loin sur le groupe socialiste et
je si vous avez des interrogations sur
le CM de retraite celle d'abord le tri
parmi les positions de votre premier
secrétaire et votre premier traité
délégué sur la catégorie active
simplement pour vous dire Monsieur le
Sénateur que la suppression de la cause
d'achèvement est aussi au programme je
crois que c'est attendu par bon nombre
d'agents publics et enfin vous me
permettrez de conclure en disant
simplement que nous allons aussi ouvrir
la retraite progressive aux agents
publics vous conviendrez avec moi que
c'est aussi attendu merci Monsieur du
socle j'espère que l'intervention de
Monsieur Savoldelli sera mieux écouté
monsieur le monsieur le ministre
on aura une réponse quand même à ma
question à celle de notre groupe puisque
sur cette vidéo et vous le savez
monsieur le ministre la Commission
nationale de l'information des libertés
a été saisie suite à de nombreuses
plaintes donc la question est sérieuse
et elle mérite une réponse mais
néanmoins sur le fond vous continuez à
défendre votre effort irresponsable et
impopulaire et alors c'est comme si elle
était déjà votée et là vous vous croyez
tout permis ça se voit dans la vidéo ça
se voit dans les déclarations
d'Élisabeth borne qui nous dit que les
64 ans ne sont pas négociables mais
écoutez l'opinion publique la rue vous a
encore parlé hier des milliers des
millions de personnes sont sorties
manifestées contre votre réformes
injuste le message il est clair vous
aurez beau communiqué vos éléments de
langage et utiliser ce que j'appelle un
yoyo anti-démocratique avec le 49-3 le
47 ans et pourquoi pas les ordonnances
mais je vous le dis monsieur le ministre
à votre gouvernement madame borne les
jeunes les femmes les travailleurs les
retraités ils sont pas dupes alors dans
cette vidéo je vous demande monsieur
Guérini a parlé dans cette vidéo de
faire un effort collectif à toute la
nation et aux agents des fonctions
publiques et bien je vous demande avec
solennité et esprit de responsabilité à
mon tour d'accepter votre erreur et de
retirer cette réforme où tout le monde
est perdant et dont personne ne veut
la parole
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Michel
Dagbert pour le groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes c'est
indépendant
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Jean-Christophe con ministre
des Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées elle intervient un
an après le début de l'affaire dite
ORPEA et les révélations sur la face
cachée de certains EHPAD à travers le
livre de Victor Castanet beaucoup se
sont alors émus de ces pratiques
scandaleuses dénoncées dans cet ouvrage
le gouvernement avait quant à lui réagi
notamment en lançant une enquête
administrative de l'IGAS à l'initiative
de la ministre chargée de l'autonomie
Brigitte bourguignon et une enquête
financière aujourd'hui la prise de
contrôle d'Orpea par la Caisse des
Dépôts vient d'être officialisé celle-ci
en devenant majoritaire c'est désormais
l'État qui sera aux manettes et nous ne
pouvons qu'espérer des répercussions
positives sur le fonctionnement de ces
établissements mais au-delà c'est
l'ensemble des métiers du social et du
médico-social dont il s'agit et de la
prise en charge des personnes âgées des
personnes handicapées des adultes en
difficulté sociales ou de la protection
de l'enfance encore qui sont soumis à
une double pression monsieur le ministre
ils doivent en effet répondre d'un côté
aux exigences bien légitimes des usages
des usagers de leur famille quant à la
qualité des prestations fournies mais
ils sont aussi confrontés aux impératifs
budgétaires prenant parfois la forme
d'injonction émanant de leurs employeurs
privés ou semi-publique cette double
exigence explique en grande partie la
perte d'attractivité de ces emplois et
les difficultés de recrutement qu'il
rencontre actuellement à titre d'exemple
les instituts de formation nous
indiquent que 30% des étudiants arrêtent
avant la fin de leur cursus je sais
Monsieur le Ministre très attentif aux
travaux de préconisations émises par le
Haut Conseil du travail social dans ces
différents rapports je vous sais
également et ne doute pas de l'intérêt
que vous portez à la fois aux
professionnels concernés et aux
personnes dont ils ont la charge
pouvez-vous alors nous indiquer les
dispositions que vous comptez prendre
pour que les professionnels du
médico-social puissent rester les
acteurs de la bienveillance à l'égard
des plus faibles d'entre nous merci pour
vos réponses la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Christophe combe ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateur monsieur le sénateur Dagbert je
vous remercie pour votre question
l'investissement annoncé ce jour de la
Caisse des Dépôts mais aussi d'autres
acteurs du secteur de l'assurance
notamment est un signal positif pour le
groupe ORPEA qui va pouvoir ainsi
accélérer sa transformation c'est une
bonne nouvelle nous le souhaitions c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour l'emploi c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour le secteur mais
surtout pour le bien-être des salariés
pour le bien-être des résidents mais
aussi de l'ensemble des familles vous
savez c'est un marqueur aussi fort de
l'engagement de l'État dans le secteur
du grand âge je le rappelle c'est sous
l'impulsion du président un public qu'en
2020 le gouvernement a créé la 5ème
branche la sécurité sociale la branche
autonomie qui sera dotée de 9 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires tout au long de
ce quinquennat 9 milliards pour
accélérer le recrutement dans les EHPAD
pour augmenter les salaires mais aussi
pour améliorer la qualité de vie au
travail de toutes celles et ceux qui
s'engagent dans ce secteur c'est 9
milliards d'euros aussi pour transformer
l'offre pour plus de domicile pour des
EHPAD modernisés pour des EHPAD plus
ouverts plus verts mais aussi pour
financer un plan inédit de lutte contre
la maltraitance dans ce secteur pour
cela on aura besoin de tout le monde du
secteur associatif d'un secteur
associatif sans doute plus innovant d'un
secteur public aussi plus efficace d'un
secteur privé exemplaire mais vous
l'avez dit la question majeure à
laquelle nous devons répondre
aujourd'hui c'est celle de
l'attractivité des métiers c'est une
question complexe et vous vous doutez
que à cette question complexe on peut
pas apporter de réponse simple c'est
pour ça qu'on a choisi de produire un
certain nombre de propositions et de
mesures
supplémentaires qui vont faire un plan
on répondre à l'urgence notamment en
qualifiant les faisant fonctions dans
les établissements en augmentant les
salaires avec le Ségur de la santé les
183 euros supplémentaires pour tous les
personnels soignants et du secteur
éducatif en renforçant aussi la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
dans tous les établissements mais aussi
en améliorant
l'organisation de du travail à domicile
avec les deux heures supplémentaires
tout ça pour nous permettre d'atteindre
l'objectif de recruter 50 000 soignants
supplémentaires dans le secteur c'est un
objectif ambitieux et on n'est jamais
assez ambitieux lorsqu'il s'agit du
bien-être de nos parents
la parole est maintenant au président
canner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et République
je suis le président madame ministre
pour la quatrième fois consécutive nous
vous interrogeons sur la réforme des
retraites et je crains que pour la
quatrième fois consécutive ou persistez
il y a 10 jours le ministre du soft nous
disait que cette réforme était destinée
à rétablir un maximum d'égalité hier il
nous a dit que ce texte allait nous
permettre d'assister sans ce texte
pardon nous allions assister une baisse
de 20% du niveau moyen des pensions des
retraités vous-même vous le défendez en
insérant d'une démarche de défense du
modèle social français Madame Brigitte
Macron même elle a dit qu'il était
nécessaire pour assurer une retraite aux
jeunes pendant ce temps-là le président
de la République la juge indispensable
qu'on pense qu'on part à l'Europe bref
mes chers collègues une réforme idéale
la mère de toutes les réformes
alors que demande le peuple bien le
peuple vous a donné hier dans la rue
toute génération et tout territoire
confondu une éclatante réponse le peuple
ne veut pas de votre effort de ce nouvel
impôt sur la vie que vous défendez avec
obstination quoi qu'il en coûte ce que
nous savons c'est que le rendement
financier pour reprendre votre
expression madame le Premier ministre de
votre réforme sert à faire des économies
sur le dos des ouvriers des employés
qu'ils soient issus des classes
populaires comme des classes moyennes
mais ces économies ne pouvez vous pas
les faire ailleurs que les chaînes
Français les plus modestes ce que nous
savons c'est que vous voulez offrir au
président de la République sa grande
réforme alors désolé mais nous l'avons
cure de l'ambition personnelle
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a d'autres
priorités quand la fracture sociale
s'aggrave quand l'inflation rogne le
pouvoir d'achat des petits salaires
quand des étudiants des salariés pauvres
et des personnes âgées font la queue aux
soupes populaires écoutez les Français
et répondez à ma question quand
allez-vous retirer votre réforme des
retraites très bien merci monsieur le
président
la parole pour vous répondre à Madame
Elisabeth borne première ministre merci
monsieur le président
mesdames monsieur le Président canner
moi des principes essentiels en
politique
dire la réalité aux Français sans tordre
les chiffres sans vendre des illusions
sans relayer des contre-vérités
alors monsieur le Président parlons de
fait
parlons de fait aujourd'hui le nombre
d'actifs qui cotisent diminue par
rapport au nombre de retraités c'est un
fait dans les années 50 il y avait
quatre actifs pour un retraité
il n'était que deux au début des années
2000 ils sont 1,7 aujourd'hui et l'on
sait que ce nombre continue à diminuer
et ça ça n'est pas une opinion politique
monsieur le Président kaner c'est une
réalité démographique une réalité qui
menace notre système de retraite par
répartition
de ce fait notre système de retraite
sera en déficit dans les prochaines
années des déficits qui vont s'accumuler
et là encore ça n'est pas moi qui le dis
ça n'est pas le gouvernement qui le
décrète c'est un fait un fait partager
le par le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites
et je vous le rappelle et je vous le
rappelle au 15 scénario au 15 scénario
du corps ne prévoit l'équilibre en 2030
d'ici 10 ans ce sont près de 150
milliards d'euros de déficit que nous
accumulerons si et que nous laisserons à
notre jeunesse si nous ne faisons rien
c'est pour cela que le premier président
de la Cour des comptes a déclaré la
semaine dernière que notre système de
retraite n'était pas soutenable en
l'état et qu'une réforme était
indispensable voilà pour les faits
monsieur le Président canner alors
passons aux conséquences ce dont nous
avons discuté avec les organisations
patronales avec les organisations
syndicales avec les différents groupes
parlementaires c'est d'assurer l'avenir
de notre système de retraite par
répartition en travaillant
progressivement plus longtemps
c'est ce qu'on fait tous nos voisins
européens c'est aussi le choix que des
majorités c'est ce qu'on fait tous nos
voisins européens c'est aussi le choix
que des majorités de droite et de gauche
ont fait avant nous et je vous rappelle
monsieur le Président kaner que vous
avez vous-même avec le Parti socialiste
soutenu la réforme de Madame Touraine
qui allait exactement dans ce sens
[Applaudissements]
alors vous avez changé d'avis monsieur
le président
leg si vous l'écoutez pas la réponse je
doute que le président Kanner puisse
ensuite répondre alors laissez madame la
Première ministre exprimée le président
kaner répondra madame la Première
ministre
autre droit mais
aldel social et pour combler ce déficit
il n'y a que deux autres options soit
vous voulez baisser les pensions et vous
pénaliserez les petites retraites et les
classes moyennes en les privant du fruit
du travail d'une vie soit vous voulez
augmenter drastiquement les cotisations
et les impôts pesant sur les salaires ou
pénalisant les artisans les TPE les PME
tous ceux qui font notre vie économique
brisant ainsi la dynamique de l'emploi
alors monsieur le Président Kanner
puisque nous partageons une volonté
commune de vérité dites-nous quelle
alternative vous proposez aux Français
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat ou la
hausse du chômage
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
notre projet est animé par une seule
volonté assurée l'avenir de notre
système de retraite par répartition
alors nous portons un projet qui permet
le retour à l'équilibre en 2030 en
travaillant progressivement plus
longtemps et je mesure ce que cela
représente pour beaucoup de Français et
je sais que nous ne sommes pas tous
égaux devant le travail c'est pourquoi
nous avons veillé à répartir le plus
équitablement possible l'effort
notamment en tenant compte de la
situation de ce qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt ou qui ont des métiers
difficiles et je veux souligner aussi
désormais les femmes partiront en
moyenne plutôt à la retraite que les
hommes alors que c'est le contraire
aujourd'hui enfin cette réforme
permettra d'augmenter les plus petites
pensions des futurs retraités comme des
retraités actuels nous pourrions
peut-être au moins nous retrouver sur ce
point puisqu'il était porté par votre
candidate à l'élection président
bien sûr nous entendons les inquiétudes
et les doutes nous sommes prêts à
enrichir le texte et je ne doute pas que
le Parlement y contribuera nous
travaillerons avec toutes celles et ceux
qui partagent notre volonté de préserver
notre modèle social je vous remercie
mais monsieur le Président Calais une
poignée de seconde pour répondre dans le
calme
madame la Première ministre
votre réponse est une réponse
inéquitable vous demandez aucun effort
au plus aisé de nos concitoyens c'est
votre choix vous êtes la premier niche
des plus riches manifestement moi je
tiens à vous donner
ce mot ce mot dans une manifestation
hier écoutez-le et sortez de votre
équation comptable nous ne sommes pas
des feignants nous voulons juste
profiter un peu du fruit de notre
travail avant de mourir madame la
Première ministre ayez un peu de
bienveillance vis-à-vis des Français
retirez votre réforme
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant monsieur
Jean-Yves roux pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres en juillet 2022
rappelons-nous nos sapeurs-pompiers se
sont engagés pour lutter contre des
incendies dévastateurs nous étions mes
chers collègues très nombreux à nous
rendre compte combien l'action des 51900
pompiers professionnels et volontaires
mobiliser nuit et jour nous étaient
indispensables en ce début d'année
l'envers de la médaille est pourtant là
dans nos territoires sa médiatisation
particulière mais dans sa réalité la
plus crue aujourd'hui en effet nos
services d'incendie de secours notamment
ceux de la réalité croix sous le poids
financier des charges supplémentaires
accumulées par des responsabilités qui
leur incombe ainsi que le sel qui ne
leur income pas sa ressource suffisante
pour réaliser leurs missions
mes chers collègues nos pompiers puisque
jamais ils font face conséquences du
réchauffement climatique incendie
inondations éboulement cela ne s'arrête
pas nos pompiers assurent de plus en
plus des soins de premiers secours dans
les déserts médicaux parcourant des
kilomètre qui coûte très cher cela ne
sera pas non plus de sitôt bien sûr ça
peut pompier professionnel et volontaire
interviennent avec le courage le
dévouement qui les caractérise mais
jusqu'à quand et dans quelles conditions
car l'inflation et la crise énergétique
sont passés par là je la capacité
d'action de notre sécurité civile des
communes et départements contributeurs
du 10 n'arrivent pas à régler les
factures exceptionnelles assumer les
nouvelles charges de personnel non
compensées et ne peuvent plus investir
pour disposer d'un matériel niveau
acceptable au-delà des difficultés
conjonctuelles majeures pour lesquelles
nous demandons à l'état d'intervenir
nombre d'élus membres des 10 dresse le
constat d'un modèle de financement qui
n'est plus exploiter aux charges
croisantes nos sapeurs-pompiers or en
matière de sécurité civile tout défaut
d'investissement ne pardonne pas
monsieur le ministre sauvé ou péril
telle est la devise de nos
sapeurs-pompiers pour aider maintenant
les 10 fortement fragilisés pour
réformer les modes de financement et
pour pouvoir plus de péricquois sur
entre 10 au nom de la solidarité
nationale quelle sera donc la vôtre je
vous remercie
RC on vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais pas sur le constat
que vous avez fait nous le partageons au
gouvernement c'est tellement vrai que la
loi matras que vous avez d'ailleurs voté
ici prévoyez que le gouvernement
organisé finalement l'audit de notre
système de sécurité civile et son
financement ce rapport m'a été rendu et
je l'ai rendu public auprès des élus
auprès des 10 et bien sûr auprès des
organisations professionnelles de
sapeur-pompiers et des organisations
volontaires de sur vos pieds moi aussi
je veux comme vous l'avez fait les
remercier pour leur travail extrêmement
difficile de cet été mais finalement
tout au long de l'année que qu'évoque ce
rapport il évoque pas finalement déjà la
part des financements et je constate
personne ne le dit jamais que l'État
alors même que vous le savez bien les
îles ont été décentralisés depuis 2001
l'État finance InCar du fonctionnement
des 10 et qu'il y a à sa tombe de
difficultés de financement notamment la
TSCA la taxe qui avait été jadis
imaginée pour pouvoir intervenir dans le
financement des disques qu'elle à la
fois très dynamique mal répartie et que
souvent parfois certains départements ne
renverse pas l'intégralité de cette taxe
vous le savez à la collectivité
suggénériste qu'est le 10 troisièmement
il y a effectivement un sujet entre des
départements pauvres ou qui sont et
parfois ce sont les deux en face de feu
de forêt ou de manque important de
médecins avec des carences que nous
connaissons et nous avons évoqué et puis
des départements plus riches où il y a
souvent moins de feux de forêt et par
ailleurs il y a plus de présence
médicale et donc il y a la question de
financement de l'État les tailles est
prêt le président de la République a
déjà fait un bande-annonce et le rapport
Falco va nous aider à aider davantage
S10 il y a évidemment le travail
sécurité civile et réchauffement
climatique avec notamment la question
aérienne très importante et puis comme
vous l'avez très bien dit vous-même
monsieur le sénateur la répartition
entre les collectivités de manière la
péréquation entre les 10 en tout cas le
gouvernement est à votre disposition
pour avancer et dans les prochaines loi
de finances pour mettre fin à ces
difficultés il veut aussi soutenir les
propositions loi nombreuses notamment de
vos collections de tous les banques qui
prévoit sur la prévention des risques
beaucoup de travail on est tout à fait
prêt à vous accompagner
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
maintenant madame Monique de Marco pour
le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire
merci
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues avez-vous entendu parler
du robot j'ai pété ce fameux logiciel
d'intelligence artificielle qui suscite
de vivre réaction et de nombreuses
dérives j'ai d'ailleurs testé ce robot
pour cette question
l'intelligence artificielle peut être
formidable outil si elle est
correctement utilisée et quoi de mieux
que des cours de technologie dès la 6e
pour former nos enfants à ses nouvelles
technologies pourtant vous ne semblez
pas être du même avis monsieur le
ministre puisque le 12 janvier vous avez
annoncé par voie de presse la
suppression de la technologie en sixième
au collège cette annonce brutale a été
un coup de tonnerre pour la communauté
enseignante cette décision verticale n'a
été ni présentée ni discuté ni-concerté
elle traduit une méconnaissance totale
des enjeux du 21e siècle en effet pour
réussir la transition écologique qui
s'impose à nous la France a de plus en
plus besoin d'une jeunesse ouverte aux
sciences et aux technologies les
méthodes d'apprentissage propre
discipline expérimentales développent
l'esprit critique stimule la créativité
et contribue à la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire
cette suppression serait guidée par des
choix budgétaires sans aucune
considération pédagogique vous souhaitez
renforcer l'accompagnement des élèves à
mathématiques et en français mais sans
investir dans l'école de la République
puisque vous n'avez pas concerté et pour
susciter votre intérêt pour cette
matière j'ai donc choisi d'interroger
chaque GPT pour formuler ma question
la voici voici sa réponse le
gouvernement peut-il détailler les
motivations et les conséquences prévues
de la suppression de la technologie en
6e et comment cela impactera les
compétences futures des jeunes dans un
monde de plus en plus numérique je
termine par l'être humain que je suis
souhaite rajouter quel calendrier prévu
pour une information officielle et
cadrée qui va réellement assurer le
soutien prévu en français en
mathématiques et dans quelles conditions
et tout simplement quel avenir pour la
technologie
merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Pape Ndiaye ministre de
l'éducation nationale et la jeunesse
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de Marco je n'ai pas besoin
d'intelligence artificielle pour vous
répondre l'école de la République ne
peut pas laisser de côté un quart un
tiers des élèves de 6e avec des
difficultés possiblement insurmontables
en français et en mathématiques et comme
je l'ai annoncé en effet à la rentrée
2023 des sessions de soutien ou
d'approfondissement dans ces deux
disciplines fondamentales auront lieu et
seront mises en place pour les élèves de
6e pour pouvoir assurer ces sessions
donc à partir de 2023 sans alourdir les
horaires de classe des élèves de 6e
effectivement nous allons concentrer de
technologie sur les classes de 5e de
quatrième et de 3e dans ce cadre la
discipline de technologie sera confortée
madame la sénatrice et je suis donc très
clair
ni suppression de la technologie au
collège ni relégation de cette
discipline au contraire nous devons
faire de telle sorte que cette
discipline soit revalorisée de manière à
ce qu'elle puisse susciter des vocations
des vocations pour le numérique
d'évocation pour les sciences de
l'ingénieur d'évocation pour la voie
professionnelle y compris dans
l'équilibre entre filles et garçons
concernant les professeurs de
technologie leur situation personnelle
seront préservées et ils bénéficieront
en vue de l'adaptation des programmes de
cinquième quatrième et troisième d'une
formation que je souhaite diplômante
pour l'année
2023-2024 tout cela est actuellement
discuté avec les associations de
technologie c'est conditions-là que nous
allons améliorer le niveau de nos élèves
et c'est ici à cette condition que la
technologie confortera sa place au
collège et c'est bien mon intention
c'est la parole est maintenant à Madame
Vanina paoliaga pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre une
partie de la solution est dans les
territoires je ne peux pas être plus en
accord avec vous monsieur le ministre
octroyez 2 milliards d'euros via le fond
vert afin de répondre aux besoins des
territoires en matière de transition
écologique est une décision de bon sens
l'écologie de proximité l'écologie de
l'action est déterminante de la réussite
de nos objectifs
nos forces et notre dynamisme pour la
transformation se trouve dans nos
territoires
nos élus locaux sont les acteurs majeurs
et pivots du dispositif ils connaissent
parfaitement les attentes les projets et
les évolutions de leur territoire pour
transformer les C ils doivent être
accompagnés d'une offre d'ingénierie
solide c'est décisif pour se mettre en
capacité de délivrer monsieur le
ministre
certains projets toutefois ne semblent
pas rentrer exactement dans le cadre
actuel de votre fond j'ai pour ma part
initié avec le Petr haute-armance dans
l'Aube sur deux intercommunalités un
projet de boucle énergétique rurales qui
serait une première en France en
ruralité il s'agit de combiner
production d'énergie verte flexibilité
et stockage pour créer un circuit court
de consommation d'électricité et faire
baisser les coûts de l'énergie ce projet
d'autoconsommation collective à vocation
à hybrider différents types de bâtis à
la fois privés publics et pour ce
dernier du bâti de l'État et du bâti des
collectivités il entre dans aucune case
et pourtant il a le mérite de soulever
l'enthousiasme de nos concitoyens en
zone rurales et de redonner monsieur le
ministre de l'espérance outre le fait
qu'il répond concrètement en mode
collaboratif à des questions très
prégnantes cette initiative au Boisse
n'est qu'un exemple parmi d'autres
monsieur le ministre comme on le fond
vert peut-il intégrer ses innovations
locales qu'elle souplesse prévoyez-vous
dans son déploiement et envisagez-vous
de l'ouvrir plus largement je vous
remercie
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique la cohésion des
territoires
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Paoli
vendredi dernier
les formulaires
permettant de commencer à demander le
fond vert ont été mis en ligne
six jours après j'ai fait le relevé
juste avant d'arriver ici
1800 collectivités ont déposé un dossier
au titre du fond vert
on peut s'en réjouir collectivement
parce que c'est d'abord la preuve de la
volonté des collectivités territoriales
ce dont je pense personne ne doutait de
se saisir de la transition écologique et
de la faire vivre comme vous l'avez dit
de manière concrète de manière tangible
en regardant comment accompagner nos
concitoyens on aura l'occasion de
préciser tout ça mais les deux premières
demandes c'est la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments et c'est la rénovation de
l'éclairage public mais toutes les
lignes depuis le littoral la montagne en
passant par la renaturation font l'objet
à ce stade d'ouverture et de demande
votre question elle porte en dehors des
14 cas qui ont été identifiés comme
étant les portes d'entrée naturelle sur
les boucles énergétiques
ces boucles locales elles bénéficient
aujourd'hui d'ores et déjà de deux types
de financement hors fond vert
le premier qui est pas forcément le plus
simple mais qui est pourtant puissant ce
sont les c2eux et le deuxième c'est le
fond chaleur de la dame qui ici
d'ailleurs dans cette émission à
l'occasion des débats a fait l'objet
d'un confortement pour être porté à plus
d'un demi milliard d'euros et j'ajoute
que parallèlement à ça le soutien a des
boucles énergétiques dans le cadre des
zones industrielles bas carbone est
engagé et soutenue notamment par le
ministère de l'Industrie pour regarder
comment là où nous avons des industriels
qui décarbonent on peut faire en sorte
d'en faire profiter le tissu de
proximité je vous invite vraiment à
regarder de manière très étroite avec la
dame comme on pourrait avoir des projets
pilotes de boucles locales énergétiques
locales et je suis à votre disposition
pour vous accompagner parce que je crois
que c'est le type de modèle qui permet
de montrer à nos concitoyens qui a une
écologie de progrès concrète bonne pour
le climat pour le pouvoir d'achat et
pour l'emploi
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre on
va examiner ces dispositifs merci la
parole est maintenant madame Béatrice
Gosselin pour le groupe les républicains
ma question ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer en 2022 le nombre de
titres de séjour autorisant à résider et
à travailler en France a augmenté de
plus de 17% par rapport à 2021 ainsi
plus de 320 000 titres ont été délivrés
contre un peu plus de 277 000 en 2019
qui sont les qui est la dernière
référence significative avant la
pandémie jamais la France n'attribué
autant du titre de séjour et accueilli
autant de demandeurs d'asile alors
qu'elle peine toujours à expulser des
illégaux qui vivent sur son territoire
cette situation difficilement tenable
témoigne de l'incroyable pression
migratoire qui pèse sur notre pays car
comme vous le savez on dénombre près de
700 000 clandestins sur le sol national
ces chiffres sont en total décalage avec
le discours offensif de votre
gouvernement sur la question des
expulsions de clandestin certes si vous
privilégiez la qualité sur la quantité
en reconduisant prioritairement les
délaissants et les terroristes étrangers
sortant de prison il n'en reste pas
moins que les procédures d'éloignement
recensés par vos services sont au nombre
de diles 9425 pour 2022 et ce chiffre
reste en deçà de celui d'avant la crise
sanitaire en effet Monsieur Castaner a
ordonné presque 24 000 retondus
reconductions à la frontière en 2019
résultat un quart d'expulsion en moins
par rapport à 2019 et cela correspond à
moins de 3% du nombre de personnes se
trouvant en situation irrégulière sur le
sol français
la maîtrise des flux migratoires doit
imposer de reconduire effectivement les
immigrés illégaux pour accueillir des
ayants droits dans les meilleures
conditions cela suppose des intentions
fermes et des actes clairs alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple qu'attendez-vous pour mettre fin
à cette situation à soutenable pour
notre pays
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice on peut être d'accord sur un
certain nombre de constats peut-être pas
surtout notamment le fait que la
comparaison avec 2019 peut paraît un peu
biaisée dans la mesure où deux grands
États qui aujourd'hui sont des états de
demande d'asile vous avez raison de dire
que cette demande asile explose
d'ailleurs partout en Europe plus 60% de
la ville en Europe en 2022 seulement je
mets des guillemets évidemment plus de
30% en France à l'époque en 2019
l'Afghanistan et le Mali nous avions des
relations convenables et beaucoup vous
savez la première demande d'asile en
France et en Europe c'est l'Afghanistan
ce sont les Afghans qu'on ne peut pas
évidemment reconduire et je ne parle pas
à des Iraniens si je connecte nos
discussions on met pas fort reproché
d'avoir fait un syndrome de
reconnaissance avec la Syrie avec l'Iran
par exemple cependant vous avez
parfaitement raison les titres de séjour
augmentent nous pensons que la politique
gouvernement et la bonne puisque pour la
première fois ces titres augmentent pour
le travail et stagne pour la famille le
problème de la France c'est un
groupement familial trop important un
petit de travail trop peu importante
contrairement à l'Allemagne par exemple
et puis évidemment vous avez raison
aussi sur les éloignements et même si je
vous remercie d'avoir remarqué qu'on
double le nombre de personnes qui sont
soit radicalisées soit criminelles ou
délinquants dans les expulsions plus de
3000 étrangers délinquants expulsés la
dernière contre 1500 en 2019 vous avez
raison c'est 15% d'augmentation ne sont
pas suffisants et qu'est-ce que nous
attendons mais nous attendons de
discuter avec les assemblées du projet
de loi que j'ai justement eu l'honneur
de présenter au Conseil des ministres ce
matin il faut libérer le droit on met
parfois deux ans à 2 ans et demi par une
décision de justice définitive quand on
est mise à l'intérieur pour pouvoir
expulser et entre temps les personnes
ont peut-être fait un enfant sur le
territoire de la République ils ont
peut-être travaillé illégalement sur le
peut-être pu proposer d'autres demandes
de titre de séjour il faut absolument
mettre fin à ses détournements de
procédures il faut évidemment pouvoir
expulser des personnes en relevant les
protections juridiques la fin de la fin
de la double peine c'est ce que nous
proposons et il faut évidemment avoir un
discours extrêmement clair
en vertu d'intégration les valeurs de la
République et la langue mais aussi
vis-à-vis des États qui sont des états
d'immigrations et donc oui madame la
sénatrice nous partageons le constat et
nous pensons que pour les Français il
faut un texte fort qui permet de
l'intérieur de pouvoir expulser plus
rapidement ces personnes
merci Madame Gosselin poignée de seconde
oui monsieur le ministre merci de votre
réponse je vois que cette loi est en
présente préparation mais il est vrai
que les français s'inquiètent de cette
montée en puissance des émigrés et je
crois que une politique de situation
claire et ferme permettra d'accueillir
mieux les gens qui peuvent venir sur ce
territoire français merci
la parole et maintenant madame Angèle
Préville pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et République
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est la
marée blanche de troo cette pollution
plastique irréversible et fatal à la
biodiversité et malheureusement
récurrente sur nos plages depuis le mois
de décembre la côte atlantique est
polluée par des granulés de plastique
industriels de l'homme Pornic le
Finistère la Bretagne les Pays de Loire
ont porté plainte contre X vous avez
déclaré monsieur le ministre nous
pouvons être fiers d'être le pays le
plus ambitieux en matière de lutte
contre ces granulés merci monsieur le
ministre de reconnaître notre travail
parlementaire puisque c'est grâce à un
amendement que j'ai porté lors de
l'examen de loi AGEC que les entreprises
doivent adopter des procédures prévenant
la dispersion des granulés mais Monsieur
le Ministre l'amendement voté au Sénat
était beaucoup plus contraignant
puisqu'il obligeait les entreprises à
déclaré les pères du Sud du granulés
malheureusement votre majorité à
l'Assemblée avait raboté le dispositif
en CMP alors que j'ai ont m'opposé
l'engagement volontaire de la plasturgie
n'étant pas du genre à m'avouer vaincu
j'ai récidivé par une proposition de loi
adoptée à nouveau à l'unanimité au Sénat
en réinscrivant en article 1 à nouveau
cette obligation pour les entreprises de
déclarer les pertes de granulés de
plastique merci à mes collègues pour
leur confiance par conséquent monsieur
le ministre vous avez un véhicule
législatif à votre disposition pour une
action très concrète mais la France
n'est pas la seule concernée le naufrage
du porte container Express Pearl en 2021
au large du Sri Lanka a provoqué sans
doute la plus grande marée blanche qu'on
n'est jamais connue vous pouvez aussi
œuvrer au niveau international à la
création d'un fonds d'indemnisation à
l'instar de celui qui existe pour les
marées noires et qui s'appelle le people
la production plastique monsieur le
ministre est en croissance exponentielle
porter plainte c'est un peu court
monsieur le ministre n'est-il pas temps
d'encadrer davantage cette production
merci
pour vos vraiment la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Préville d'abord je
vous remercie pour votre question et je
voudrais remercier le sénateur Joël
Gueriot
qui en nous alertant sur ce sujet il y a
déjà 15 jours à précisément permis que
il y a à la fois un degré dans la
vigilance qui soit franchie et un dépôt
de plainte avec Hervé Berville que nous
avons rendu effectif le vendredi qui a
suivi les questions gouvernement ici au
Sénat deuxièmement la situation que vous
décrivez elle s'est étendue à la Manche
et à une partie des côtes flamandes à
l'occasion du week-end puisque cette
fameuse marée blanche qui a commencé au
niveau de la Vendée puis de la
Loire-Atlantique
renforçant très fortement la présomption
qu'il s'agit bien d'un container compte
tenu de la traînée avec laquelle nous
nous retrouvons j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire un que on savourait pas non plus
vaincu par rapport au sujet que la loi
âgée quelle que soit l'appréciation
comporte sur le degré de vigilance elle
est effective depuis le 1er janvier 2022
que nous venons de terminer sa première
année d'expertise et j'ai annoncé que
les rapports d'audit que nous attendons
désormais sur cette site par site seront
publiés pour qu'on s'assure que
l'effectivité de ce dispositif soit
effectivement totale la suite c'est fin
mai à Paris c'est la façon dans le cadre
international d'obtenir dans le cadre du
traité d'élimination des plastiques que
nous puissions faire en sorte que CGPI
c'est granulés plastiques individuels
soit effectivement beaucoup mieux
encadré à une échelle mondiale d'autant
que dans la continuité de ce que nous
constatons sur nos côtes un certain
nombre d'enquêtes ont permis de révéler
à quel point le phénomène se retrouvait
à fortiori avec beaucoup plus d'ampleur
dans d'autres pays et sur d'autres
continents montrant l'étendue de ce
fléau donc nous partageons votre
indignation nous partageons notre
volonté d'agir nous partageons surtout
la volonté de faire en sorte qu'on ait
un cadre international contraignant en
attendant de mesurer si les premières
mesures prises sur le front national
sont suffisantes ou s'il convient de les
renforcer un an après leur mise en œuvre
merci
poignée de seconde madame Préville merci
monsieur le ministre pour la réponse
mais je vous avais demandé par rapport à
ma proposition de loi qui est inscrite
au bureau de l'Assemblée nationale si
elle pouvait être votée puisqu'elle
propose un cadre beaucoup plus
contraignant par rapport à ces granulés
plastiques merci
la parole est maintenant Madame
Christine bonfantido ça pour le groupe
les républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le 8 décembre dans un entretien
à la presse vous annonciez avec fierté
une baisse de la délinquance je vous
cite une baisse timide mais une baisse
quand même hier tombé des chiffres de la
délinquance dans notre département
violence sexuelle plus 11%. cousez bien
sûr plus 14%. cambriolage plus 11% vol
de véhicule plus 9% avec
879 victimes de crimes en 2022 nous
sommes désormais face au niveau le plus
élevé depuis 30 ans
ces chiffres ne proviennent ni de Libé
ni de l'humanité ce sont les chiffres
officielles de votre ministère est nul
ne pourra dans les contester mais
derrière ces chiffres il y a des
réalités il y a des Françaises et des
Français qui vivent dans la peur
l'insécurité est devenu une triste
réalité qui n'a cessé de croître pendant
les quinquennats d'Emmanuel Macron mon
département de Lot-et-Garonne à l'image
de tous les départements souffrent
cruellement de cette politique le
quotidien de nos forces de l'ordre est
extrêmement difficile manque de moyenne
humain et de matériel découragement le
mot est faible absence de réponse pénale
des voyous qui font la loi partout et
qui n'ont peur de rien ni de personnes
oui les policiers et les gendarmes se
font ce qu'ils peuvent mais encore
faudrait-il des condamnations fortes
vous ne pouvez pas sans cesse renvoyer
la faute sur vos prédécesseurs
l'insécurité monsieur le ministre n'est
pas une fatalité elle est le résultat
d'un manque de courage et d'une absence
de volonté politique monsieur le
ministre face à cette délinquance
explosive le gouvernement est-il
vraiment en capacité de protéger les
Français
merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur des Outre-mer ah pardon
alors un monsieur le garde des sceaux
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice puisque la justice selon
vous n'est pas au rendez-vous de ces
obligations cette question à l'origine
fléchée pour le ministre de l'Intérieur
je vais me faire un plaisir d'y répondre
d'abord voyez-vous en deux minutes c'est
une gageure que d'évoquer ces questions
de la délinquance
quelle est la part dans l'augmentation
ou éventuellement la diminution de
certaines infractions du confinement
quelle est la part de libération de la
parole dans les violences intra
familiales plus de force de l'ordre
c'est aussi plus de fées constater sur
le voie publique et d'une certaine façon
une augmentation de la délinquance je me
permets de vous le dire les escroqueries
on en a davantage mais nous avons mis en
place une plateforme Thésée qui permet
de mieux les appréhender la justice
madame la sénatrice c'est durant cette
période un taux de poursuite de plus de
de plus pardon 13%. et les peines en
matière correctionnelles entre 2017 et
2022 sont passés en moyenne peine ferme
de 6,7 mois à 8,3 mois donc la justice
n'est pas laxiste elle est au
rendez-vous des obligations qui sont les
siennes et parler une fois encore en
deux minutes de la délinquance
franchement c'est une gageure ça mérite
de plus amples explications
de reconnaître que le Président de la
République est davantage collectionneurs
que joueurs
[Applaudissements]
la parole
[Musique]
la parole et madame monsieur Jean-Michel
Arnaud allez allez on se calme bien
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre des
Solidarités nous avons donc appris ce
matin par voie de presse que l'accord de
prise de contrôle du groupe ORPEA par la
Caisse des Dépôts a été finalisé cette
nuit la CDC va désormais détenir cinq
ans virgule 2% du capital cette manœuvre
celle la volonté de la puissance
publique de sauver un groupe privé à la
dérive une telle opération intervient en
réaction à l'un des plus grands
scandales sanitaires à la suite de la
parution du livre les fossoyeurs de
Victor Castanet toutefois le tableau
d'ensemble que cela dessine interroge
d'un côté l'état use d'un puissant
instrument financier pour sauver un
grand groupe à but lucratif de l'autre
une majorité des pâtes publiques et
abusent non lucratif souffre d'un manque
de moyens humains et financiers partout
en France les questions sur le ministre
sont donc simples quelle est la vision
gouvernementale la problématique de la
dépendance de nos aînés
plus précisément au vu du vieillissement
de la population et de l'accroissement
des besoins en matière de dépendance que
comptez-vous faire afin que les logiques
de marché et la pression de quelques
actionnaires à vide ne primentent sur la
satisfaction de l'intérêt général je
vous remercie
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Christophe combe ministre
des Solidarités de l'autonomie des
personnes handicapées merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur Arnaud la
semaine dernière je répondais à une
question de votre collègue madame la
sénatrice Michel meunier pour dire tout
ce qui a été fait et réalisé par l'État
depuis le depuis que le scandale hors pa
a éclaté et vous le voyez chaque semaine
la situation évolue j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure mais je ne commenterai pas plus
une opération financière en cours même
si je crois que nous ne pouvons que nous
en réjouir et effectivement l'état
accueille extrêmement favorablement
cette nouvelle qui va permettre
d'accélérer la transformation du groupe
ORPEA et d'aller dans le bon sens mais
cependant il n'y a pas que le groupe
ORPEA vous l'avez rappelé et en tant que
ministre de l'autonomie j'ai la
responsabilité de renforcer la confiance
des Français dans leurs EHPAD j'ai la
responsabilité de transformer un secteur
pour pouvoir permettre de préparer notre
pays au vieillissement de la population
ça passe d'abord je l'ai rappelé aussi
tout à l'heure par des soignants mieux
reconnus dans leur engagement des
soignants plus nombreux mieux rémunérer
avec un investissement plus fort dans la
qualité de vie au travail de ceci ça
passe par des familles aussi et des
résidents rassurés ça passera en effet
par une accélération de la
transformation de l'offre c'est ce qu'on
a voulu faire aussi avec l'accélération
des contrôles tous les EHPAD je le
rappelle seront contrôlés d'ici à la fin
de l'année 2024 c'est ce que nous
faisons en mettant en place un grand
plan de lutte contre l'Allemagne
traitance et c'est ce qui a été fait
pour la première fois et puis c'est ce
que nous faisons aussi avec est-ce que
je fais en poussant les investisseurs
aujourd'hui à regarder et à se tourner
plus fortement vers l'intérêt général
c'est important et j'ai toujours dit que
le rendement économique soit mis au
service du progrès humain en particulier
dans ce secteur et j'attends de ces
investisseurs qui qu'il montre
aujourd'hui leur exemplarité
merci
Monsieur Jean-Michel Arnaud oui monsieur
le ministre j'entends votre réponse qui
me satisfait que partiellement
le contribuable mais un milliard d'euros
pour sauver un groupe à la dérive un
groupe qui est facturé des prix de
journée démentiel à des seuls fins de
satisfaire l'actionnariat je pense que
dire que l'on se satisfait de cette
situation c'est imaginer que l'État
n'est plus un état protecteur n'est pas
un État providence un état brancardier
l'État intervient sous la pression d'une
enquête de presse vous nous dites
effectivement avoir entendu le résultat
et les messages adressés à l'occasion de
la dérive de ce groupe je vous mets au
défi effectivement de relancer une vraie
politique en direction des personnes
âgées et une loi dépendance digne de ce
nom d'une part et d'autre part
d'accélérer et d'amplifier le contrôle
sur les établissements but lucratifs
l'argent ne doit pas être l'élément
moteur de l'accompagnement de nos aînés
c'est inacceptable et je crois
nécessaire qui est une réaction forte de
l'État pour protéger nos plus
vulnérables je vous remercie
la parole
la parole est maintenant monsieur André
Richard pour le groupe les républicains
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre Christophe Béchu celui ministre
nous vous avons dans cet enceinte
plusieurs fois interpellé sur les graves
difficultés de
occasionnées par la hausse du coup de
l'énergie à la fois sur les particuliers
les entreprises mais également les
collectivités locales permettez-moi
aujourd'hui de revenir plus
particulièrement sur ces conséquences
pour les communes celle-ci ont bien
entendu engagés pour la plupart d'entre
elles au moins différents plans de
sobriété énergétiques de l'année
dernière mais si les effets commencent
tout doucement à apparaître ceci reste
naturellement minime par rapport à
l'impact exorbitant des charges
d'énergie sur le budget ou projet de
budget 2023 par ailleurs alors qu'elle
supporte totalement les nouveaux prix du
gaz le bouclier tarifaire pour certaines
l'amortisseur électricité et le filet de
sécurité ne suffisent naturellement pas
au maintien des équilibres financiers
précédents en effet l'explosion des
coûts de l'énergie outre ses
préoccupations directes à bien d'autres
effets induits sur d'autres postes des
budgets des communes telles les
augmentations des contrats de
maintenance des prestations de services
et bien d'autres ainsi il n'est pas rare
que de ce seul fait l'augmentation des
dépenses de fonctionnement d'une année
sur l'autre dans la préparation du
budget 2023 soit de l'ordre de 20 % et
rendent impossible le vote d'un budget à
l'équilibre monsieur le ministre il
convient de tout faire pour encore mieux
accompagner ces collectivités locales en
2023 j'ai à cet égard deux propositions
à vous faire ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
serait utile de prononcer une
suspension temporaire pour 2023 du
prélèvement annuel que subissent un
grand nombre de communes de notre pays
pour insuffisance de logements sociaux
tels que le prévoit l'article 55 de la
loi SRU
j'ai bien dit suspension pour 2023
ensuite du fait de la hausse du coût de
l'énergie le montant de la TVA sur ses
factures s'envolent à du proportion dès
lors que les collectivités locales ne
peuvent pas récupérer cette taxe comment
leur éviter cette double peine
allez-vous les faire profiter en retour
des sommes ainsi perçues je vous
remercie de votre réponse c'est la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Richard
vous l'avez dit face à l'explosion de
ses factures énergétiques un certain
nombre de dispositifs ont été mis en
place je n'y reviens pas pour les plus
petites boucliers l'amortisseur pour les
autres et puis ces filets de sécurité au
cœur de l'été dernier avec le concours
actif de la majorité sénatoriale la fois
par rapport au montant et par rapport au
contour et puis dans le cadre de la loi
de finance avec un montant d'un milliard
et demi d'euros et des conditions qui
ont été assouplies que ce soit sur la
baisse de l'épargne ou que ce soit sur
la porte d'entrée du dispositif on est
au tout début de l'année les premiers
chiffres dont on dispose que je
considère comme n’étant pas signifiant
sur l'épargne et sur les dépôts auprès
du Trésor au 31 décembre montre qu'on a
plutôt une progression des crédits mais
on ne peut pas à ce stade les détourer
par strate de collectivité et on sait
que toutes ne sont pas impactés de la
même manière deuxièmement le filet de
sécurité on en voit pas encore
totalement les effets puisqu'on est dans
les premières semaines on a eu des
demandes au titre de l'année dernière de
plus de 4000 collectivités déclenchant
plus de 100 millions d'euros de
décaissement au-dessus de dispositifs
2022 mais le milliard et demi qui est
sur la table aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
dans quelle mesure il va être utilisé ma
priorité aujourd'hui c'est d'abord qu'on
regarde rapidement
la réalité de la consommation
prévisionnelle de ce filet de sécurité
pour savoir s'il a été correctement
dimensionné vous faites des propositions
elles ont le mérite de se trouver dans
un esprit de co-construction mais j'ai
un peu de mal à comprendre la première
sur la suspension du prélèvement de
l'article 55 lié à la carence de
logements social parce que ça voudrait
dire que les communes qui ont plus de
25% de logements sociaux les aideraient
pas et que celles qui ont moins et qui
se retrouvent dans une situation de
rattrapage celle-là bénéficierait d'une
aide ce serait quand même surprenant de
récompenser la carence au lieu de
récompenser celle qui au contraire on
fait en sorte de faire une partie du
chemin donc ma proposition elle est
simple à ce stade qu'on regarde
l'effectivité du filet de sécurité pour
mesurer s'il convient de la maudier de
le modifier puisqu'on a un engagement
bud important avant d'aller mettre en
place des nouvelles propositions
RC la parole est maintenant monsieur
Denis bois pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et République
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la Fondation a bien été ce
matin sont 28e rapport sur l'état du mal
de logement en France les femmes sont
des premières victimes de ce mal
logement les maires célibataires dans un
tiers sont pauvres vivent souvent de
délogements précaires et sous
dimensionnés pour les Français modestes
et même pour les Français de conditions
moyennes le parc locatif privé est
totalement inaccessible aucun territoire
de ce cette France était épargner
l'insuffisance des réponses publiques
pour rendre le logement abordable fait
qu'aujourd'hui plus de 12 millions de
Français de Français se trouvent
fragilisés
ces dernières années vous le savez les
aides au logement et le logement social
à travers le préservement sur la RLS la
hausse de la TVA ont été la cible de
l'économie budgétaire de l'État
conséquence conséquences la production
avec moins de 85000 logements construits
en 2022 une diminution de 30 % par
rapport à 2017 désormais 2,3 millions de
ménages sont en attente d'un logement
social alors oui oui monsieur le
ministre vous avez mis des moyens en
matière d'hébergement d'urgence pour
autant les ouvertures de place
d'hébergement ne suffit pas à faire une
politique globale du logement
l'accompagnement social de la politique
du logement reste d'abord insuffisante
ne parcours résidentiels sont à l'arrêt
d'après carliner la précarité
énergétique s'accroît en ce sens
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple
face au Costa de la Fondation Abbé
Pierre toujours plus douloureux chaque
année comptez-vous changer le cap de la
politique du logement de ce gouvernement
pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre délégué
chargé de la ville et du Logement
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Denis vous avez raison le
calendrier est celui de la présentation
du rapport de la Fondation Abbé Pierre
ce matin et j'y étais comme tous les ans
présent pour échanger et faire valoir la
réalité de l'action du gouvernement oui
il y a des mâles logés en France oui
nous nous battons chaque jour tous je
crois pour que cette situation ne dure
pas le gouvernement vous l'avait dit
c'est engagé et a maintenu les places en
hébergement d'urgence et surtout le
gouvernement précédent a lancé le plan
quinquennal logement d'abord le plan
quinquennal logement d'abord c'est celui
qui fait sortir de la précarité celui
qui fait sortir de la rue celui qui fait
sortir de l'hébergement d'urgence est
une réussite est une réussite majeure
440 000 personnes grâce à ce plan sont
sortis de la rue de l'hébergement
d'urgence pour avoir un logement c'est
plus de 200 000 places de des personnes
qui ont réglé leurs problèmes que lors
du quinquennat de François Hollande et
c'est un succès à mettre au profit du
gouvernement précédent ce matin on
conseille des ministres avant d'aller à
la Fondation Abbé Pierre à la demande du
Président de la République et de la
première ministre j'ai présenté le futur
plan logement d'abord qui sera une
priorité du gouvernement de faire aussi
bien de continuer à accompagner les plus
fragiles et les plus précaires mais vous
avez raison pour pouvoir réussir cette
politique du logement il faut construire
plus il faut construire plus là où il y
en a le plus besoin il faut comme on l'a
dit tenir nos engagements en termes de
sortie des passoires énergétiques il
faut tenir nos engagements en termes de
lutte contre l'habitat insalubre il faut
tenir de nos engagements en termes de
réhabilitation des copropriétés
dégradées c'est tous ces sujets que le
gouvernement est que la première
ministre ont souhaité mettre au débat
lors du Conseil national de la
refondation sur le logement c'est tous
ces sujets sur lequel nous travaillons
que nous co-animons avec christophe
Robert le président de la Fondation Abbé
Pierre et Véronique Béda qui anime à mes
côtés le travail du CNR logement et je
peux vous assurer que nous ferons des
propositions à la hauteur des besoins
merci
monsieur boide
monsieur le ministre j'entends vos
réponses et je sais l'effort que vous
faites mais enfin il manque cruel de
logements social dans ce pays vous savez
comme moi que les prélèvements que vous
avez fait au travers de la RS sur les
bailleurs sociaux font qu'aujourd'hui
non plus les moyens de construire de
logements vous savez très bien que sur
la problématique de la population de ce
pays avec 70% de gens qui sont éligibles
au logement social c'est du pouvoir
d'achat que vous lui donnez alors vous
avez dit vous-même la bombe sociale de
demain voilà la réponse que vous avez
dit concernant le logement social
effectivement monsieur le ministre fait
un temps de marcher pour le pour le
logement
c'est la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Laurent Burgaud pour le groupe
les républicains merci
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la Fédération Française de la
course camarguaise et sous la tutelle du
Ministère des Sports et après les
corridas se sont mène à notre traditions
camarguaises qui sont menacées en effet
dans une tribune de publier dans le
journal Le Monde une cinquantaine d'élus
animalistes ou écologiste donc 11 du
conseil municipal de Montpellier ont mis
le feu à la Camargue et à la Petite
Camargue emilite pour l'abolition des
lâchés de taureau dans nos rues la
suppression de l'utilisation d'un
crochet lors des courses camarguaises
mais aussi des ferrades et de l'escosur
nos festivités camarguaises représentent
au-delà d'un enjeu économique certains
un enjeu culturel important pour de
nombreuses communes dans les
départements du Gard mais aussi de
l'Hérault des Bouches-du-Rhône et du
Vaucluse madame la ministre avant le
grand rassemblement en faveur de
traditions camarguaises prévues le 11
février prochain à Montpellier ma
question est double quelle est la
position du gouvernement face à ces
menaces et apportez-vous votre franc
soutien à notre additions je vous
remercie
merci
pour vos réponses
la parole est à Madame Rima Abdul Malak
ministre de la Culture
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Burgoa je crois qu'en 2 minutes
je ne vais pas pouvoir embrasser toutes
les dimensions soulevées par votre
question surtout que en tant que
ministre de la Culture je pensais vous
répondre sur le dossier UNESCO porté
pour inscrire au patrimoine immatériel
les courses camarguaises et toutes les
traditions qui sont associées bon en
fait vous n'en avez pas parlé mais je
voulais vous dire que ce dossier et je
vous en parle puisque je suis ministre
de la Culture
et que j'en profite aussi pour saluer le
travail qui avait été fait en 2021 par
les sénatrices Catherine Dumas et
Marie-Pierre Monnier sur le patrimoine
culturel immatériel tout ça est lié à
votre intervention puisque ce patrimoine
culturel immatériel il comprend les
pratiques les représentations les
expressions les connaissances les
savoir-faire mais aussi tous les
instruments les objets les artefacts les
espaces culturels qui leur sont associés
voilà pourquoi
récemment nous avons obtenu
l'inscription des savoir-faire de la
baguette de pain dont nous sommes très
fiers
et juste vous dire
je vais vous dire le nombre de dossiers
qui arrivent tous les jours
et qui nous intéresse aussi non mais
parce que tout cela montre la la
richesse la diversité des traditions
locales qui font partie du patrimoine
français mais je veux citer aussi
d'autres dossiers qui sont importants le
carnaval de Guyane le biou d'Arbois
fête annuel vitivinicole dans le Jura
les couvreurs zingueurs de Paris
Lorie Tahiti une pratique polynésienne
culturelle sociale très importante les
Jeux floraux de Toulouse non mais c'est
l'occasion d'en parler messieurs et
mesdames les sénateurs
joute poétique depuis 700 ans voilà pour
ce qui est de cette richesse du
patrimoine culturel immatériel français
allez allez allez on se calme on se
calme bon allez un peu de calme monsieur
Burgaud a vous avez 53 secondes pour
nous parler l'UNESCO merci monsieur le
Président je ne voudrais pas vous madame
la mistrature mais je regrette que la
ministre de tutelle madame la ministre
des Sports ministres de tutelle de la
Fédération Française de la course
camarguaise vous n'avez pas le dernier
répondre madame les gens de la Bouville
vont apprécier cela alors que c'est vous
votre ministère de tutelle alors mes
chers collègues en 1926 à la demande du
marquis folklboroselli le peintre a
représenté la nation camarguaise avec sa
désormais célèbre croix elle représente
nos gardiens et nos pécheurs et
incarnent trois vertus la foi la charité
et l'espérance le peuple de Camargue
espère que ces traditions perdureront
malgré les attaques de ces entités
[Applaudissements]
allez
allez allez
merci merci
Monsieur collègues de ne pas transformer
l'enceinte en arène allez dernière
question par le monsieur le Président de
Laffont pour le groupe Union centriste
merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Clément Baude
ministre délégué chargé des transports
les contrats de plan est à région
symbolise
l'indispensable travail commun entre
conseils régionaux et état depuis 40 ans
qu'il existe ils ont fait preuve de leur
utilité pour aménager nos territoires et
définir ensemble les investissements
publics nécessaires à ce jour l'ensemble
des cpvr 2021-2027 ont été signés mais
sans les volets mobilité je rappelle que
sur les CPR précédant les volets
mobilités représentés environ 60% des
crédits de ces contrats de plans le
volet transport a été encapsulé pour
reprendre l'expression de Jacqueline
Gouraud pour tenir compte des grandes
difficultés de financement des projets
en cours
sans empêcher l'avancement dans les
autres thématiques si des avenants ont
été signés pour débloquer des crédits en
2021 et 2022 il ne portait évidemment
que sur les projets inscrits dans le
CPER
2015-2020 ma question va faire écho un
appel lancé par les 15 présidents de
région dans une tribune il y a quelques
semaines dans le journal de monde dans
lequel ils appelaient à New Deal
ferroviaire et soulignait l'importance
des contrats de plan pour parvenir nous
sommes monsieur le ministre le 1er
février 2023 et les régions sont prêtes
à travailler et à signer ces volets
mobilités mais ils n'ont elles n'ont
aucune indication sur le calendrier de
la part de l'État aussi pouvez-vous nous
indiquer à la fois la méthodologie que
vous souhaitez mettre en oeuvre et
surtout le calendrier de signatures de
ces volets mobilité merci pour vos
réponses la parole est à monsieur
Clément bonne ministre délégué chargé
des transports
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Lafont vous avez raison de
souligner l'importance de cet outil de
programmation de cet outil
issu de la décentralisation entre l'État
et les régions les contrats de plan est
à région existent depuis à peu près 4
décennies et le choix avait été fait
vous l'avez rappelé il y a maintenant 2
ans d'avoir une discussion spécifique
sur le volet mobilité de ces contrats de
plans et je le sais il y a
urgence et impatience c'est
compréhensible nous avons je vous le
rappeler aussi pendant les années 2021
et 2022 continuer le financement des
projets l'État a été au rendez-vous il
est encore en ce début d'année 2023 pour
continuer à financer des projets qu'il
n'y ait aucune année blanche de
financement de nos infrastructures nous
avions pris l'engagement sous autorité
madame la Première ministre que nous
devions attendre le rapport du Conseil
d'orientation de l'infrastructure pour
être cohérent avec la nouvelle
programmation globale des
infrastructures que nous allons proposer
construire dans les prochains mois pour
être précis dans les prochaines semaines
sans doute au cours du mois de février
nous adresserons au préfet de région du
côté de l'état des mandats qui
permettront d'engager concrètement la
négociation de ces volets mobilités pour
la période 2023 2027 avec chacune des
régions l'objectif que je me que nous
allons le fixer si la négociation le
permet mais je pense que c'est souhaité
et réaliste nous allons parler avec
région de France en particulier pouvoir
conclure ces volets mobilités d'ici
l'été pour répondre à votre
interrogation sur la méthode et sur le
calendrier un mot sur le fond même si
nous avons encore un certain nombre de
points clarifier avec les régions
évidemment ces CPAS devront s'adapter à
une nouvelle réalité et à une urgence
climatique encore plus grande et donc la
partie ferroviaire de ces contrats de
planétari région sera absolument crucial
il faut que la part du ferroviaire dans
cette nouvelle génération de contrat
souhaite augmenter ce qui ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'y aura aucun crédit
consacré à d'autres modes de transport
notamment la route et à sa décarbonation
c'est indispensable pour beaucoup de
territoires mais nous devrons avoir
cette priorité très claire dans les
contrats de projet état région un autre
souhait aussi que porte la première
ministre que nous avons évoqué notamment
avec Carole delgas et que je crois qu'il
faut qu'au-delà des infrastructures ces
contrats à l'occasion de le
contractualiser des politiques
intermodal et de report modal plus
largement avec l'ensemble des régions et
d'associer dans la négociation à la fois
les jetons les intercommunités les
intercommunalités pardon et les
départements pour bien préparer cette
génération très attendue de contrats
2023 2027 je vous remercie c'est une
poignée de seconde donc
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance la prochaine séance de questions
d'actualité aura lieu le mercredi 8
février à 15h la séance d'aujourd'hui
sera reprise à 16h45 pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi relative à
l'instauration d'un nombre minimum de
soignants par patient hospitalisé la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du Sénat au gouvernement et
on va commencer avec